[Music]
today we celebrate and we remember
because we promised once that we would
never forget that brutal attack
on american lives american rights
and american soil by fundamentalist
terrorists on the morning of september
11
2001 i was teaching back-to-back
sections of american heritage
and in between the two sections a
student came up to me he was incredibly
flustered and he told me about the
events going on in new york city but
everything
was confused later that morning my wife
deidra
and i ran into president arn who
informed us
quite rightly that hillsdale would
continue to teach
all day because it's exactly what the
terrorists would not want us to do
2977 americans died on september 11th
my favorite story and one that never
ceases to move me is about one of the
passengers of flight 93
a man by the name of tom burnett who was
a 38 year old wall street banker
a father of three daughters and a devout
husband
he helped two other men drive a jet
airliner into rural pennsylvania soil
on that clear september morning we're
all going to die
but three of us are going to do
something about it i love you honey
those were his last words on his cell
phone to his wife
and i'm reminded of one of the greatest
of republican martyrs
marcus tulia cicero who was executed by
his own
executive in 43 bc and right before he
died
he wrote in a note to his son he said
before our time
the customs of our ancestors produced
excellent men
and these excellent men preserved our
ancient customs and the institutions of
their forefathers
but the republic when it came to us was
like a beautiful painting
whose colors were already fading with
age and our time has not only neglected
to freshen
the colors it has not even preserved
the original ones and it has not taken
the time
to keep together the frame its general
outlines
of the republic itself for what is now
left
of these ancient customs on which it was
said the republic of rome was founded
firm
they have been as we see so completely
buried in oblivion
that they are not only no longer
practiced they are almost forgotten
what would i ever say of these men
for the loss of our customs is due to
our lack of men
and for this great evil we must not only
give an account
but we must even defend ourselves in
every possible way
as if we were accused of murder
for it is through our faults not by any
accident
that we retain the name of republic but
have long since
lost its spirit cicero may have written
this in 43 bc
but could this not be america now and
yet
no matter what in this season of
confusion all of the sacrifices of 9 11
remain so let us remember those voices
who were silenced on 9 11. let us
remember the victims
let us remember the first responders let
us remember the heroes
may our colors never fade may our voices
never cease
and may our skies rage liberty and
sacrifice
you